-The president participated
in an ABC town hall
with undecided voters
last night,
where he lied
as often as he breathed.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
ABC invited Trump to a primetime
town hall last night,
for some reason and,
honestly, I'm
not sure I see the value
in hosting an event like this.
We know what he's gonna say.
He's gonna repeat
the same deranged lies
we've heard a million times.
The only TV show it would be
worth having Trump on
is "Ellen's Game of Games."
Then, at least,
we could see him lie
and drop into a pool full
of jelly beans
or get sprayed with a hose
full of chocolate sauce.
Of course, you know,
that's probably --
probably what he wants.
[ As Trump ]
Oh, no, not the
chocolate sauce hose.
Really, the best
you can hope for,
with a town hall like this,
is a new lie
for reporters to debunk.
[ As Trump ]
You know, they say
coronavirus can be cured
by swallowing a golf ball
covered in Emergen-C
while shining a laser
pointer up your butt.
And then, the reporters say,
"Oh, that's a new one!
Quick, someone fact-check that!
This one's gonna get us
the Pulitzer."
Although, I will say the one
genuinely valuable service,
with a town hall like this,
is watching normal
people interact
with a nutjob like Trump.
Anchors and reporters,
they all adhere
to a certain level
of decorum and tradition,
even though Trump is
an obvious crazy person,
but normal people
react differently
because they've had
experience with it.
When you ride the bus or the
subway to work every day,
you interact with your
fair share of Trumps.
Most people just ignore
the dude on the subway yellin'
about mind control cockroaches
stealing our cigarettes.
But if Wolf Blitzer
ever rode the F train,
he would have to say...
[ As Blitzer ]
Sir, what's your proof of that?
I'm sorry.
We're out of time.
We'll have to leave it there.
Case in point, last night,
a voter asked Trump
about his repeated attempts
to repeal Obamacare
and do away with its protections
for preexisting conditions,
including a lawsuit
his administration has filed
with the Supreme Court,
and, when Trump tried
to interrupt her,
she asked him to let her finish.
-Should preexisting conditions,
which Obamacare brought into --
brought to fruition, be removed
-No.
-without --
Please stop and let me
finish my question, sir.
-Oh, it's so cathartic
to see someone
put Trump in his place
like that.
Can we please let her
moderate all three debates,
and can we hold them
in middle school, so,
every time Trump
gets reprimanded like that,
he has to sit in the corner,
facing the wall?
That's what happens
when Trump steps
outside his
right-wing media bubble.
Most of the time,
he surrounds himself
with sycophants and yes-men,
so he's rarely treated like
the idiot blowhard he is.
Fox News hosts
don't interrupt Trump
when he calls in
to "Fox & Friends"
and rambles for an hour.
The hosts just sit there,
staring blankly into the camera,
like they're posing
for passport photos.
They look like those
out-of-town tourists
in Times Square,
watching Elmo drop his pants
and take a dump on the sidewalk.
In fact, Fox News is apparently
so shocked and disturbed
by the idea of Trump
answering questions from voters
that Laura Ingraham played
a montage of those questions
with the lower-third...
Man, they just never, ever stop
making excuses for him.
Look, it's not a "gotcha" book
when Bob Woodward tells you
he's recording
the interview for a book
and it's not an ambush
if you're invited to participate
in a town hall and you say yes.
When Washington wanted
to ambush the Hessians,
he crossed the Delaware River
secretly,
in the middle of the night.
He didn't send them
an invitation on parchment,
that said...
Seriously, these people
are such fragile babies.
He's the president.
You're telling me
voters ask him questions
about his record is an ambush?
You guys sound
like whiny teenagers
who just got called
to a family meeting.
Tyler, is this marijuana
I found in your bedroom?
"You went in my room?!
This is an ambush!
I'm going to Scooch's
lake house for the weekend!
I mean, I was going, anyway,
but, now, I'm gonna use
this ambush excuse.
Also, I need that weed
because [ Indistinct ]
I promised Scooch and I feel
like it would be a big deal
if I don't show up with weed.
What?
Oh, my God!
That's a "gotcha" question!"
But the exchange
about healthcare
and preexisting conditions led
to one of Trump's
most infuriating lies --
that he's the one protecting
preexisting conditions,
when, in reality,
he is currently suing
in the Supreme Court
to get rid of them.
And, when Stephanopoulos
fact-checked him to his face,
Trump repeated
yet another absurd lie
about a supposedly
forthcoming healthcare plan
that definitely does not exist.
-You've been promising
a new healthcare plan.
We interviewed --
I interviewed you
in June of last year.
You said the healthcare plan
would come in two weeks.
You told Chris Wallace,
this summer,
it would come in three weeks.
You promised an executive order
-I have it already.
-on preexisting --
-But you've been trying
to strike down preexisting
-It doesn't matter.
-conditions.
-I have it already
and it's a much better
plan for you
and it's a much better plan.
-Yeah, man, totally.
I'm sure we'll see
that healthcare plan as soon
as we see those tax returns.
It makes sense
that this guy owned casinos
because he talks about policy
like a inveterate gambler
is in deep with a loan shark.
[ Changes accent ]
"I'll get you your money.
Just give me two weeks.
Three weeks, top!
Tom Brady's never let me
down before.
Oh, wait!
He's on the Bucs now!
Ay ay ay!"
[ Laughing ]
And if that lie
sounds familiar to you,
it's because Trump has repeated
a version of it
at least 16 times, according
to The Washington Post.
Trump lies about healthcare
in interviews
the way Billy Joel plays
"Piano Man" at concerts.
He might start out
with the new stuff,
but, eventually, he's gonna
heave that heavy sigh
and strap on the harmonica.
And, look, there were too many
lies in this town hall
to keep track of,
which, again,
is why it makes no sense
to do it, in the first place.
But if you are gonna do it,
then you should at least
have a journalist
like Daniel Dale on standby
because, after the town hall,
he ran through
all his fact-checks on CNN
as quickly as he could.
-There was just so much
lying, Don.
I'm gonna go quickly here,
so literally just stop me
whenever you need to.
He said again,
Democrats won't protect people
with preexisting conditions.
That is nonsense.
He insisted he didn't
praise China on the virus.
He did so repeatedly.
He claimed that Biden said,
in March,
that the pandemic was
"totally overexaggerated."
I can find no evidence
that Biden ever said that.
He said that protesters
took over 20% of Seattle.
It was a six-block area,
nowhere close to 20%.
He said he essentially
repealed Obamacare
by getting rid
of the individual mandate.
Not even close to true.
He did his usual false boast
about so-called bans on travel
from China and Europe.
They were not complete bans.
This is a preliminary list.
I have hours of fact-checking
tonight to do
because there is
even more than this.
So this was just a fire hose
of lying, again,
from the president.
-[ As Trump ]
Better than a fire hose
of chocolate.
Just kidding.
That's my favorite kinda hose.
My God, someone get
that man some oxygen.
I half expected an arm to reach
out with a cup of water,
like he was running a marathon.
Trump lies so much,
he's turned fact-checkers
into auctioneers.
In order to fact-check
a Trump town hall,
reporters have to talk like
they're describing
the side effects at the end
of a drug commercial.
So, the lies were
too numerous to count,
but an especially
revealing moment came
when Stephanopoulos asked Trump
about his repeated attempts
to downplay the threat
of the coronavirus.
Last week, we found out,
from his taped interviews
with journalist Bob Woodward,
that Trump privately knew
how dangerous the virus was
and admitted, in his own words,
that he wanted
to always play it down.
Remember, in public, Trump
was saying stuff like this...
-It's a little like the regular
flu that we have flu shots for.
A lotta people will have this
and it's very mild.
They'll get better very rapidly.
They don't even see a doctor.
They don't even call
a doctor.
We show cases,
99% of which
are totally harmless.
We lose thousands of people
a year to the flu.
We never turn the country off.
We lose much more than that
to automobile accidents.
We didn't call up
the automobile companies
and say, "Stop making cars.
We don't want any cars anymore."
-I mean, if someone made a car
that killed over 900,000 people
across the world
in eight months, then,
yeah, I mean, we'd probably
stop makin' that car.
"You know, honey,
I like the Toyota Camry a lot,
but what do you think
about the Dodge Death Trap?
It has no doors or seatbelts
and the airbags have been
replaced with knives,
but it's a really cool blue!"
Second, we don't ban all cars
because we know how
to make cars safer
and we have laws regulating
how to make them,
who can drive them,
and how fast they can go.
If you wanna compare
the situations,
then you should be fine
with COVID laws regulating
large crowds, but instead,
you're the one breaking laws,
in states like Nevada,
and holding giant cough-a-thons
in indoor arenas.
You might as well make everyone
lick the doorknob
when they walk in.
So that's what Trump
was saying in public,
but, in private, as we now know,
he was telling Woodward
the virus was deadly,
as we heard in yet another
new tape released on Monday.
-It's a monster --
-How is it possible
for the same person
to sound so completely different
from one conversation
to the next?
Trump is our first
were-president.
He almost sounds semicoherent
on the phone with Woodward.
I think what's going on here is,
when he wants
to impress someone
he thinks is important,
like Woodward,
he tries to sound
like he knows
what he's talkin' about.
Then, when he wants
to lie to his supporters,
he goes out and says stuff like,
"Coronavirus
is basically just a rash.
All you need is some ointment
and an oatmeal bath."
So Trump knew
how deadly the virus was
and admitted, in his own words,
that he played it down
and, yet, he once again lied
during the town hall
when he was asked
about those comments.
-All through January
and February,
you you were downplaying,
by your own admission,
the severity of the crisis,
that you didn't wanna
panic people.
-Not downplaying.
-Let me just finish
the question, first.
-Not downplaying.
-Well, you said those
are your words.
-I don't want to drive
our nation into a panic.
-Why would you downplay
a pandemic that is known
to disproportionately harm
low-income families
and minority communities?
-Yeah, well,
I didn't downplay it.
I actually, in many ways,
I up-played it,
in terms of action.
So, that was called action,
not with the mouth,
but in actual fact.
-Well, it's like
they always say,
"Actions are stronger
than mouth."
"I up-played it,
not with the mouth,
but in actual fact,"
sounds like a poorly
translated bus ad
you'd see in a foreign country.
The president is
less coherent than a Sim.
In fact, he'd make just
as much sense
if he spoke the Sim language,
instead of whatever language
he normally speaks.
[ Footsteps stomping ]
-[ Sims voice ] Issa pomp zoom
ziebal dube
[ Laughing ] per ka wassum furs.
-So Trump, once again, claimed
he didn't wanna cause a panic.
This is the same guy who says
planes full of anarchists
are comin'
to destroy the suburbs.
All the guy does is panic.
He's like an old lady peering
out her front window
at a new neighbor
across the street.
"Someone's at the door.
He's wearing a uniform.
I think he's antifa!"
It's the pizza guy.
"Antizza?!"
Trump and his supporters
in right-wing media
have also been desperate to make
the presidential campaign
a referendum on the
candidate's mental fitness.
For example, twice on Fox News,
including during his interview
yesterday
with the Fox & Friends,
Trump has repeated
his deranged lie
that Joe Biden is using
performance-enhancing drugs
and, both times, the host
either nodded in approval
or teed up Trump
with a softball question.
-How do you think he goes
from incoherent to coherent?
-I think there's probably,
possibly, drugs involved.
That's what I hear.
-You have suggested
that Joe Biden
should take a drug test.
-I do. I would take one, too.
Yeah. I would say
he should take a drug test.
-You think he's taking some sort
-I do.
-of drugs to pep him up?
-I do. He's takin' something.
He's takin' something or,
you know,
gives him some clarity.
-[ As Trump ]
Probably, uh, uh,
what Bradley Cooper took,
in "Limitless."
I think it's probably
the limitless drug.
A drug that gives you clarity.
Either he knows
something we don't
or he has completely
misinterpreted Claritin.
Also, I'm sorry.
You think Biden is taking drugs?
You sniffle like you just walked
out of the bathroom
at Studio 54.
-[ Sniffing ]
-So Trump wants you
to think Joe Biden
is the one in cognitive decline
and, yet, when Trump
defended his lie
that coronavirus would
just magically go away,
he tried to claim we would
soon reach herd immunity,
which is a lie and also
incredibly dangerous
without a vaccine
and, on top of that,
couldn't seem
to remember the term.
-It would go away without
the vaccine, George.
But it's going to go
away a lot faster with it.
-It would go away
without the vaccine?
-Sure, over a period of time.
Sure, with time,
it goes away.
-And many deaths.
-And you'll develop --
you'll develop herd --
like a herd mentality.
It's gonna be --
it's gonna be herd developed
and that's gonna happen.
-[ As Trump ]
That's what I heard!
Ah, yes, it'll go away,
once we have achieved
herd mentality.
If that's the case, then I guess
Trump supporters
are already cured.
He's like a drunk guy at the bar
who claims he has
a home remedy for your cold.
[ As Trump ]
You gotta try euthanasia.
Do you mean Echinacea?
He meant to say herd immunity,
but couldn't remember it.
You know,
if Joe Biden really is
taking a magical drug
that gives him clarity,
maybe you try a little
of that, too.
I mean, how much worse
could it make you?
Every time you do one
of these insane interviews,
you sound like you just
got done huffing asbestos.
These interviews with Trump
always go the same way.
He spews too many lies to count
and then, fact-checkers
scramble to debunk everything.
He's a serial con artist
and pathological liar.
Or, to put it in Trumpese,
he up-plays the non truths...
-Not with the mouth,
but in actual fact.
-[ Laughing ] This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.